[音楽]
[拍手]
ブーバー一粋の良い地域かスイカ a におおおいて瑛太4100は良い
逆襲性について話したいと思います
a 8
していただいてええ
そこですねえとまず家
あの仮想化可愛いですね a
a 地域能力し交流会堺市如意寺
この人たちしか残れないという期以降もある思ってるんです
a そこで一番言いたいの言葉を借りしたいんですけれども
今日我々の直面する重要な問題はその問題を作って時と同じ考えのレベルで解決する
ことができません
ということはあるんですね私も本当にその通りだと思ってるんですねそれから仮想化に
よって地域に同じ
8-1推しから箱ってナイフすれば
人が備えだけではなく問題解決の静まくなっているということになります
映画の歌がしそこでですねもっと多様な人たちが集まって
例えば地元の価格とことなくた ik や経験をもっと人たちが集まれば集まることを
問題解決の可能性が機能があります
でまぁまずは私はアメリカ人としてまー要請がいいと思うことは当たり前に書くかも
しれないんですけれども皆さんどうでしょうか
例えばこういう質問もしましょう
日本にもっと多様な背景や経験を持った人たちが住むようになれば日本はすごいやすく
なるでしょうかそれとも住みにくくなるでしょうか
実はこの調査を落とし春に行われたですね
a はその結果は意外ですけれども a 棟約半数以上の日本の形は多様性に4点日本
を住みにくくなると思っているようです
しかしですね今から100円ラインで日本の人口は
明治時代時代はレベルまで下がると言われてるんですね
で+バーあと50年くらいで高齢化率が
約4割近くになるらしいんですね
そうすると例えば今日の会場にいる皆さんの中で20代の人たちが高齢者になった時に
日本の公園の立論がいいますか
もしかすると諦念対処するできない感じしないですね
a 8そうそうですねあのー
その一方ですね越冬最近日本の年度文化や
ポップカルチャーは the 世界12台変な雪を集めるのいなくてそれによって日本
に興味を持ってたずれてみたいに行かいく注意んだすごく増えているわけです
でまぁご存知のようにこの数年で延泊観光局と倍増している
しかしえーとじゃあ日本に住みないトラックときにそれがなかなか
など難しいようですね例えば先進国の中で日本は極めて外国人の人口のがイガイガまた
低いんですよ
そして a そのおっちゃんっ集中して1位カツ取っちゃてぃ池ですね
だったらしその時にやっぱりあのちょっと地元の方との相性どうかなと懸念があったの
でまず日本人中者の多い地域をやらボートで頭に付けての具合でと鴨川人も大谷の地区
でここワゴン154世代の1260名の研究やって6集落で構成されています
で a
昔は例えば一組に約20軒の家がって一見にまたて分10人ぐらいの住民が入ったん
ですけれども
ですからまあ人攻撃こういったんだね
対し気もなくては一組に数件しかなかったいい
あるいはその多くが a
定年退職の高齢者というんですか束京ノロジーの中だったんでもそれですね
ええほんと誘導で一昔前になればまあ交通スピーカされただけでこの地域はアクセス割
だったんですね
ですから当時ははちょっと久的な農村になったと言われています
しかしながらそれにもちょっと
少し前に30年前に良いですねまず1この声従者がこの g
罪
が映りするにそれによってですね
その人たちは地域に貢献したことで地元の各がもうちょっとだいぶ見たいした国になっ
たんです
そうすると若い旧車が続々甲府ウェディングになっている人たちをたければボールだな
という
ラフらしいなと思うというこの止めて移住する楽なんですね
でまぁ言ってみれば私はそのうちの一人なんです
私が例えば彼は初めて県た方が多いんで
移住しつつときにまず一つ面白いことに気づいてるんですね
それはこのかあはこの台に降りてバスを待っていたら店にお婆ちゃんが言ったんです
けれどもそのばあちゃんが国に声をかけた
通常だから東京ではこういう人なので東京力にかけられると毒の国と形でスタートか
あるいは
パッティングを練習したいとかそういう感じで恋各 coins けれどもこの
母ちゃんは何で逆に
普通の世間話をし始める
移動していくのかを見ても何もできるかどうかとかそういうことを考える以前に普通の
人間として声かけてくれたんです
それは私にとって凄く嬉しかったッ
a まあそういうことでまぁすごいいいところきたなあと思わせ実感なかったんですね
そうすると日々の生活の中で
気付いたのがこの特に地元も高齢者の方々とすごく相性がいいことかわかった
例えばまずすごく透明に見てくれるのですね
a みたいますその一方でこちらが少しを努力するだけで
すごく喜んでくれてすぐ仲良くなれるわかったんですね
ですからえっとまぁ職からも装備23のなおばあさんたちに私もすごい
インスピレーションを受けて
まあ日々のみだな生活を満喫するようになった
えっ例えば
単語をやりだしたりがありは
悪妻をやったり家
仲間小坂にをやったに
間に愛馬会をやっていた
じゃあこの実はお待ちんを毎年参加してます
このお祭りでまた大きな一打目に良いがあったんですね
デイゲットこの方でお祭りを増えている
けれどもこれ実にハグラブラブ
ことなんですね朝8時から夜に14人くらいでずーっと吹い増えている
でまぁ少し休憩が入るんですけれども
小俣理趣経を唱えが1名子なんです
でなんでそういう状況かというやっぱり仮想からません
あのした方が見えなくなって増えてる人が炊かなきゃいけないので
long river 酒場の瞳その負担が全部くるとき
で気付いたのがですね
com 地域のすべてのいろんな行事額が組織だとか匂いで同じことが言える
6カ所市道が多かった時にやり方ができなかった
で言わなくて本当に少ないんですよねその分 a 賞として星ええ
改善ができてない
なんで改善しない方て言うとババってとも守りたいとかあるいは食べたく先ほど場合に
したいの言葉どうですなかなか思いつかないかもしれないですけれども
でも改善しないと
大事なエンド病院が唱えてしまうんですね
これがファンの一番心配ですよねですからもう
結局がですねあのーその浮い2部が全部若者にかかっただけです
であのギョンミ工賃等は高齢者の方がクイーンに
まあわざと若者が日本なことも麻生してたとえ部分イチョウで誘惑が役割があるんです
か
数年に1回されが終わってきて毎月のようにいろんな
グラムで作業とか
そういう想いゲーションのあるわけなんですねその上に立てる症であるとか
いく世界とかある員は精錬会とか
さらにその皮膚を傷めて2階が働いたりと
さらに家族のお星を見たというと非常に忙しい
さらに後に五輪忙しいかもしれないですね
そうすると結局はこの地で tl は
で切ってしまうっていうかもあるんです
月で見れば仮想化において幹線
悪循環なんですね
さらに従者とか私にもこういう期待が寄せられる
私も駄文以上やってとか商談でやってくれないんだとか
いい
私としてはやそのと f 求めてやってきたのに100人ずつ場所になるかどうかなと
いうのがあってちょっと
音が皆さん気づいてないのかというのでチョコを買ったかになるん
そこでちょっと生活にメリハリを出したいということで昔に東京時代の外国人
中に遊びに来た辛くしたんですね
まずはの墓ファウンという週末回オイル以外はいカードの夜を立ちあげた
そうするとは仲間が惜しまずできるようになって
ブーブしかアップし ki 咲えっに
iot 三十路の自習の受注開発をやって
同時にですね上半身が従属
た後やいろんな活動についてかなり4編です1回に対して発信するようになったんです
ね
a piano その結果ですね私もすごく驚いたんですけれども
モーベンピックラインですね世界から4種トーナー
本陣を出せるようになったんですね
でへ
さらにルートですねアームその1てしまうからさん
移住したいという人たちが現れん
で移住してきたんですねぞう[ __ ]
でその人たちはえっ本当に私と一緒になってお祭りに参加したりあるいは暖房にし
ちゃったりと思ったに地域に対して一生懸命になってくれたんですね
すると
影響今なのでは a
それに直接移住したメンバー t 家族入れて十数名
それに例えば二拠点生活者ですとかああいうのは別の理由で記述してきて
あとで一緒になるためになるとかとしボンドの音楽のが家もいる
けれども全部130数名の30年近くのコミュニティになっちゃってるんですね
その人たちもあのまあ週末なるというか
外部からだと思う
これだけ多様な人たちが集まると本当に面白くと怒るんですね
例えばみんな集めて一層に一斉に立てるをやると思ってもなかなかそれは場所が足り
ないのでみんなで
割り勘で
空き店舗を借りてうん小学いう動きだったんですね
私たちも終わり各テーマ家賃光熱費を出して
でそのスペースを使ってない時間人はライブの地域の方に開放したんですね
a それをやったことで
例えばの地域でそれまでなかなかできなかったような大勢のお客さんを集めるイベント
がすごく手軽
できるようになったんですね
でも9由来ですとかあるいはフリーマーでですとかパーティーですか
でも一つを失うことを置きたんですけれども私たちと結構
た痴漢のことだったり旧車もう一瞬以下のスペースを運営するゆきな
ですね私は例えば食べ物何にも食べるんですけれどもこの2つ
人たち2てお食事にすごい理を持って生活していると
それでも一緒になってこういう価値観の異なったり中者同士で分かち合って共存して
助け合おうとで
スペースも地域全体も
またされるが活性化されるねっ
でその一番の哀れはですね
実はこの地域のトライから遠藤教授の復活なん
ここで越冬微ちー火薬は何10名分が前に普通に毎年まあ戻りの
やってたようですねおばあちゃんおじいちゃんってそれを懐かしく
覚えている人たちはまだ民が入っている
んですけれどもでもやっぱり先ほど説明したよねそれを捉えてしまった
ってあの不足でまぁ仲間からある日私たちはそれ子なんですね昔だけだという
である日な鎌ケ谷の国でこの釣りが痛いんですけど
言ってきて僕個人的には別密航し寝るわ
オードリー技術はあまり興味なかったんですけどまぁじゃあやろうかと
a その1中心とりあえずが代数してやったんですね
スレとですね驚くの日すっごい面白い大がかりだったんですよ
見たことないですよ
例えばがうまくに写っている
女性が漫画家なんですけど大変がプロの音楽家で普段のいろんなジャンルの音楽活動を
やっていて旨いんですね
+プロの若手を取り点が自分に10人くらいが集まってそれすごい盛り上がるんですよ
ね
さらに cd 音楽流していたんだけどその分なくねすごく彼の昔の農法の雰囲気の
現代の例えばロッキーのパパのみたいな25すごく上手に皮膚後してい
誰もがダブ死んでるなようになった
おばあジョジーちゃんでも若い人でも大臣後に40
それを見て僕はワーコレを最強の地域稼いたコンデジじゃないなと思って
来年はもっと本格的になりましょうた
それが実現したのがええ
ことし7月ですね
あのーう
第2回の王取りない
でこの大会はまず
バッグメンバー全員へこの生で
いただいて水平に簡易をだるま満額で本当に豪華が楽しいのようなようになったんです
よね
ただの参加者はもう202以上だったと思うんですよ
でまぁ出店もあったりいろんなが if の方も地元のかと思うよねーの
住所いろんな人が参加してくれ
ポイントは私たちは頑張り大変な上級をせずに結構効率よく
注意てきたんですよねこれは多分これからも
持続可能なレベルの体力できたんですよね
でポイント5がですね
私たち多様な背景やゲイ権を持ったメンバーが自分たちにとって普通の槍などを
しただけでそれが地域にトップ全然新しいヨヌ
て結果的に捉える園の行事を深くんで来たんですね
私としてはこれも本当に意味で多様性がもたらす結果でやって
対応生の銀品じゃないかなと思うんですよ
陛下の御酌この日は大山地区で初めてこれだけ
東洋たような人外国人も当時もばあちゃんおじいちゃんも子供も
や地元のたっても大和の人もみんな義手後は見なくてほどっ
お試し生んだと思います
水産市場行われちょっと覚えだした感動するんですけど
あの a
やはりあのっ
これで
あのう
これこそが
あのこれないの対応音声が本当にいいねぇー
住みやすい社会じゃないですかと思うんですよ
ぜひみなさんこれから一緒に日本語をもっとたような口にしていきましょう
ありがとうござい
[拍手]